president-elect biden spent part of
martin luther king jr day
volunteering at a food bank in
philadelphia
he's already got a packed agenda for his
first day in office tomorrow
as he inherits leadership of a nation in
crisis
senior white house correspondent weijia
zhang is in wilmington delaware wija
confirmation hearings for mr biden's
cabinet
begin this morning what's the latest
well good morning to you anthony you
know president-elect biden may have to
begin his term with a team of all
acting not permanent cabinet members
that's because even though today
the senate confirmation process begins
for five of his nominees they may not be
approved by tomorrow
meanwhile mr biden is still tweaking his
inaugural address and says speech
writing
is going well cbs news got an
inside look at the inaugural platform
and the view
from president-elect biden's lectern
where he will deliver the most
important speech of his career louisiana
congressman cedric richmond will serve
as a top advisor in the west wing
i think he's going to share his vision
for the country
he is the president for all of america
and he's going to govern that way
to govern mr biden will need a team
today senate confirmation hearings will
start for five of his cabinet picks to
lead the departments of state
treasury defense and homeland security
along with the director of national
intelligence in her opening remarks
obtained by cbs
news secretary of treasury nominee janet
yellen will call for
major financial actions now to prevent a
long-term scarring of the economy later
we're going into wednesday knowing that
we're ready to do the work
the transition has been tense with far
less coordination than usual between the
trump and biden teams
in yet another sign last night president
trump issued a proclamation
that would lift covet-related travel
restrictions for much of europe and
brazil
places where the virus is still
spreading
the biden administration quickly
rejected the move
mr biden's incoming press secretary
tweeted
the administration does not intend to
lift these restrictions
in fact we plan to strengthen public
health measures around international
travel
in order to further mitigate the spread
of coven 19.
today the president-elect is heading to
washington after an event to send him
off here
in wilmington then this evening he will
participate
in a coven 19 event with 400 lights
shining along the reflecting pool at the
lincoln memorial to honor the some 400
000 americans who have lost their lives
to the virus
gail don't be interested to see that
ceremony
we're also hearing about this
president-elect's immigration plan
can you tell us anything about that
yeah so in his very first days in office
the president-elect will introduce a
plan
that could if past legalize
citizenship for millions of immigrants
who are
living here currently without current
status he also plans to make it
easier to seek asylum along the u.s
mexico border
impose a deportation moratorium and
extend protections for
so-called dreamers tony all right i'll
take it thank you